did you know that Indiana my birthplace
and ancestral homeland didn't only give
rise to John Cougar Mellencamp and a
little ditty about jack and diane it's
also a mecca for warm beer in the
Hoosier State it is against the law for
convenience and grocery stores to sell
cold beer and one of my dad was always
so grumpy at family picnics room
temperature suds that's a surefire way
to make any gathering of kin more likely
to end in gunplay of course it's not
just Indiana that has incredibly stupid
and punishing booze laws is Colorado
Washington State and other places around
the land of the free start legalizing
pot it's the perfect time to repeal the
vestiges of alcohol prohibition that
went into effect anything before Woodrow
Wilson had a stroke in Pennsylvania with
only a few exceptions you can only buy
beer body temperature naturally at
wholesalers and we have to buy it by the
case in New Hampshire the Live Free or
Die State you'll have to die before you
can freely buy beer you can only buy
alcohol at state-run stores and even the
Soviet Union is more liberal than bad
bloody Kansas kept alcohol prohibition
in place until nineteen forty eight and
to this day you can only get three point
two percent beer at convenience stores
oh thank heaven for 7-11 Mountain Topeka
all throughout our purple mountains
majesty there are more laws regulating
the buying of booze than of sex toys the
Hoosier State may get a shot of sanity
with a beer chaser the Indiana petroleum
marketers and convenience store
Association is suing to finally sell
cold beer beer drinkers want choice and
to
change but most of all they just want a
cold brewing hand to drown out Johnny
Cougars Jack and Diane for recent TV I'm
Kennedy